a bunch of years ago where I sort of
lost my passion for my own work
and I discovered the this naturally
occurring pattern based on how the how
the human brain makes decisions that
every single one of us knows what we do
we know the jobs we do we know the
products we sell the services we offer
as companies
um some can articulate how we do those
things these are the things that you may
say are you're differentiating value
propositions the things that make you
different or stand out from the crowd
but very very few people and very very
few organizations can clearly articulate
why they do what they do and by why I
don't mean to make money that's a result
by why I mean what's your purpose what's
your cause what's your belief why does
your company exist on a level beyond
your product you know why should we get
out of bed in this every morning why
should anybody care and what I learned
is that the most inspiring the most
influential the most Innovative
companies and organizations
um and individuals all think act and
communicate the exact same way everybody
from Martin Luther King to Apple
Computers they start start with why and
so when I first realized this it not
only profoundly changed my own view of
my life and my organization but I talked
about it and I guess it resonated with
other people too for me a good y has two
pieces
um there's a contribution and an impact
to do something so that something
happens
um so like my wife for example is to
inspire people to do the things that
Inspire them so together each of us can
change our world for the better so when
I hear to make the world more agreeable
what I hear is the so that I hear the
outcome that the world is more agreeable
and the question that it raises for me
is what's your contribution what's the
specific thing that you're doing to help
make the world more agreeable